we lost Leonard Nimoy very recently and
I know that you to not only work
together him as the older Spock he was
the younger Spock but you formed
personally a really strong bond with
Leonard Nimoy yeah we were very very
close and losing him was really
difficult obviously but you know I feel
so grateful that I knew him and that he
was such an instrumental figure in my
life and and he lived a beautiful life
and a full life and and so they're
really in the end I think was much more
celebration of what he accomplished and
how many lives he touched in the world
and you know will will certainly miss
him but yeah he's an amazing man hard to
think of a bigger icon for especially
people my generation but you know at the
when I worked at The Simpsons I got to
work you know get to work with everybody
but I remember the day that we I mean
everybody you get to work with everybody
and then there was the day yeah yeah
yeah I wasn't that you you weren't
around then uh but I remembered when I
wrote an episode and we were looking we
said there was a chance that Leonard
Nimoy would do it and then he said yes
yeah came to the recording studio and I
walked into this recording studio and
there was Leonard Nimoy and I freaked
out yeah because he was such an
indelible part of my childhood and and
he just Stan he stood for and stands for
such an ideal yes
yeah the character of course but he
imbued that character with so many of
his finest qualities yeah that uh that
he really carried that energy through
his life he was an incredibly generous
and thoughtful and talented man and a
painter and a poet and a art collector
and a philanthropist and a director
Internet I mean he just he really I know
we should all be so lucky to live half
as fulfilled a life as he did so there's
sadness but you know it's it's tempered
by by the fullness of the life you lived
very nice yeah all right
I mention again the slap this is
horrific airs Thursdays at 10:00 on
NBC's everything so I love talking to
you yeah
[Applause]
you